s
jours qui ont changé sa vie...
Et ébranlé la famille royale
d'Angleterre. Nabi-Alexandre
- La princesse Diana continue
de fasciner un quart de siècle
après sa mort. Dans le film
Spencer, on met en scène
sa détresse, lors des fêtes
de Noël 1991 au palais
de Sandringham, quelques mois
avant e.
MARC LAURENDEAU
journaliste
- C'est une fable surréaliste.
Mais... et tout n'était pas,
autrement dit, tel que
l'histoire le dit. Cependant
le message lui, le message
d'ensemble, était vrai.
- Trompée par son prince, isolée
et prisonnière d'une famille
royale hostile, rigide et
lugubre. Ladi Di perd
l'équilibre, tente
de s'accrocher à ses fils
et de reprendre sa liberté.
- Et eentait
le souffle de vérité,
de spontanéité, de naturel.
Le film dit aussi qu'elle avait
des problèmes d'équilibre
psychologique, ce qui est vrai.
Ce n'est pas la seule donnseulen
cause mais on le dit bien, on
le décrit bien.
- Le réalisateur chilien
Pablo Larrain, à qui on doit
le film Jackie, propose ici
une fable qui révèle le trouble
intérieur de la princesse
des coeurs, incarnée par
l'américaine Kristin Stewart.
FRANCINE GRIMALD
journaliste culturelle
- Elle est extraordinaire
c'est une Lady Di plus vraie que
vraie, son regard, son jeu,
sa sensibilité, ses émotio
tout passe dans son regard
nostalgique et triste. Mais mon
dieu qu'on étouffe dans
ce film-là, on est sous pression
tout le temps, tout le temps
avec. On voit qu'elle est
adulée, adorée par tout le monde
sauf par ses proches.
- Les t superbes,
comme ses tenues. La princesse
des coeurs était une icône
de la mode. Elle bouleversait
les codes et contrastait avec
l'austère famille Windsor.
LOLLITA DANDOY
journaliste mode
- Lady Di c'était une rebelle.
Elle a toujours un peu défié...
défié la monarchie, défié
quelles étaient les règles et ça
se faisait encore une fois par
le vêtement. Si on y pense comme
il faut, on a peu de souvenirs
ts ou elle parlait. Mais
pourtant on a l'impression
de la connaître si bien et c'est
à cause de vêtements. Ce qu'elle
a réussi à faire, c'es
amour des vêtements, de trouver
le moyen de communiquer.
- Les contes de fée fascinent et
à plus forte raison lorsqu'on
sait qu'il se termine sur
un drame.
Ici Nabi Alexandre Chartier,
Radio-Canada, M